peine au moment même où le président de
la république poursuivant son périple
africain fait étape au burkina faso je
vous propose également de nous rendre
dans ce pays il ya peu encore appelée
haute volta depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir
il ya trois ans du capitaine thomas
sankara le burkina faso ou même ac mène
une expérience originale de
développement économique ainsi l inverse
de nombreux autres pays africains il
privilégie l'essor de l'agriculture et
fait plutôt exceptionnelle d'un tourisme
que l'on peut qualifier d'intégrer un
des agents étrangers de ce secteur
d'activité n'est d'ailleurs autre que la
compagnie charter et voyages le point
mulhouse
voici le reportage de gilles chavanel et
de joël turlin l'aide de la france pour
la reconstruction du grand marché de
ouagadougou rasé pour cause
d'insalubrité
c'était un déçu et du burkina faso à
l'occasion de la visite de françois
mitterrand aujourd'hui mais ce pays de
six millions et demi d'habitants à
vocation essentiellement agricole attend
surtout de la france qu'elles
soutiennent l'effort engagé depuis le
coup d'état d'août 83 par le président
thomas sankara à capitaine de 37 ans un
effort qui malgré le caractère marxisant
du gouvernement burkinabè devrait
séduire paris le pays veut prendre en
charge son développement économique basé
à 90% sur la culture et l'élevage
il s'appuie pour cela sur des organismes
internationaux comme les nations unies
mais surtout sur des organisations non
gouvernementales composé d'associations
et d'individus venus au burkina pour
offrir leurs services et leurs
motivations
même si parfois les résultats tardent à
venir
et on afrique tout va petit à petit elle
s'est nourrie
toute façon c'est petit à petit pour
faire avancer les choses c'est ce sont
les gens humaines peuvent prendre en
charge le développement donc c'est à lui
que leur qualité c'est comme ça c'est
gros son lustre
le trade qui sont un partage un échange
l'aide financière est en liaison un
petit accessoire pour démarrer et le
projet s'autofinancera g6 celle que
jamais le projet auquel fait allusion
josiane qui faire concerne une province
du sud ouest du burkina
son but est d'aider les jeunes sortant
de l'école primaire à rester au village
en leur apprenant à mieux tirer partie
de la terre burkinabè alsaciens et
vosgiens ont travaillé ensemble sur ce
projet une démarche similaire pour le
point mulhouse avec ses avions dû
pointer et c'est tout terrain du point
raid
l'association mulhousienne a voulu à sa
façon permettre au plus grand nombre de
découvrir le burkina faso tout en les
sensibilisant problèmes du pays parmi
ces problèmes il en est un essentiel
celui des communications
celui qui a résolu le moment de
communication a évolué en grande partie
le problème développement c'est sûr que
si il n'y avait pas le problème de
communication
on aurait peut être qu avec les régions
favorisées par la nature où il ya
beaucoup d'eau n'aurait pu augmenter et
significativement la production pour que
la partie où la fonction d'ici puissent
avoir assez à manger huitième pays le
plus pauvre du monde
le burkina faso ne veut plus entendre
parler des aides internationales en
termes coloniaux d'aucuns pourront
considérer cette démarche comme
idéologique elle l'est certainement mais
qu'importe puisque elle a pour fondement
la prise de conscience des capacités des
burkinabè à s'impliquer directement dans
le développement du pays notamment sur
le plan touristique
nous continuons nous voyons plus le tous
les sens ce sont son âne de masse plutôt
que sous l'angle sélectif
c'est pour cela que le point le pointer
et et pour nous quelque chose
d'essentiel
parce qu'il permet à des couches qui
n'aurait pas pu faire le déplacement de
venir
au burkina faso de partager la vie des
burkinabè de s'intégrer et
on participe à la lutte nationale que
nous mêmes nous reste une question
essentielle pour ce pays comme pour
beaucoup de pays africains
le poids des traditions et les luttes
entre ethnies fragilise le régime
seul le développement culturel peut lui
permettre de mener à bien ses objectifs
or pour l'instant il n'y a que 6 %
d'enfants scolarisés au burkina faso
alors qu'ils représentent plus de la
moitié de la population
gagner la bataille du développement et
de l'autosuffisance alimentaire ou passe
aussi par la lutte contre
l'analphabétisme